und jetzt
heute schon mit heinz wolf uns marietta
slomka
guten abend zu beginn einer neuen woche
mit der zugleich eine neue zeit begonnen
hat alte gewissheiten sind dahin
insbesondere deutschland hat sich auf
einen schlag von hoffnungen illusion und
politischen prinzipien verabschiedet nun
hat begonnen was man wohl einen neuen
kalten krieg nennen muss und in der
ukraine hingeht ein heißer krieg weiter
mit all dem leid und dem sterben das
damit einhergeht es gibt viel zu
berichten und viele themen die wir in
der nächsten dreiviertelstunde sortieren
wollen dazu gehört auch die frage wie
putins atomare drohungen einzuschätzen
sind und was auf die bundeswehr zu kommt
dazu später ein interview mit dem
ranghöchsten deutschen soldaten
generalinspekteur
außerdem werden wir uns anschauen welche
wirkungen die sanktionen zeigen am
ersten wochentag an dem sie in kraft
sind aber als erstes blicken wir
natürlich in die ukraine kristina k s
hat zusammengestellt welche
informationen und bilder uns von dort
erreichen
kiew heute abend eine stadt im krieg der
lärm der kämpfe ist zu hören die straßen
gespenstisch leer
der bürgermeister wendet sich an die
menschen
[Musik]
freunde
hier verteidigt sich weiter unser
militär und die
selbstverteidigungskräfte sind dabei
saboteure die in unserer stadt sind
unschädlich zu machen wir haben
befestigungen und straßensperren
aufgebaut vor den strategisch wichtigen
unternehmen und einrichtungen
und ich möchte sie daran erinnern dass
wir um die sicherheit der kinder
sicherzustellen eine ausgangssperre
verhängt haben verlassen sie ihre häuser
nicht
schwere kämpfe werden auch aus aktiv
gemeldet die zweitgrößte stadt des
landes ist zu einem schlachtfeld der
russischen invasion geworden die
regionalverwaltung spricht von angriffen
auf wohngebiete in denen es keine armee
und keine strategische infrastruktur
gebe elf menschen seien getötet worden
die russischen truppen haben in den
letzten drei stunden archiv beschossen
sie haben viele zivile häuser getroffen
wir haben viele unschuldige leute die
verletzt oder getötet wurden
zur gleichen zeit treffen zum ersten mal
in diesem krieg russen und ukrainer
zusammen viele hoffnungen dass diese
gespräche an der belarussischen grenze
das sterben beenden würden hatte wohl
kaum jemand und tatsächlich sind die
verhandlungen nach wenigen stunden
beendet ohne ergebnis und dann eine
geste verzweifelte hoffnung präsident
selensky unterzeichnet am nachmittag
eine bitte um aufnahme in die
europäische union
wir sind unseren partnern sehr dankbar
dass sie an unserer seite sind wir
wollen mit allen europäern zusammen und
was am wichtigsten ist gleichberechtigt
sein ich bin sicher dass das pferd ist
ob und wann es zu einem eu-beitritt
kommen mag für viele menschen in der
ukraine könnte es zu spät sein in einem
kieler krankenhaus kämpfen die ärzte um
das leben dieses 13 jährigen jungen
seine familie wurde beschossen sein
kleiner bruder getötet unklar von wem ob
er die nacht überleben wird wissen die
ärzte nicht nur eines von tausenden
opfern dieses krieges mitten in europa
aus kies zugeschaltet ist uns der
ukrainische abgeordnete parlaments
abgeordnete alexej gontscharenko
erhard in kiew aus guten abend
erkrankung
guten abend was haben sie heute über tag
erlebt und in welcher situation ist die
stadt jetzt im moment
in der nähe von
leider
wurde die stadt wieder bombardiert
es kann der ballistischen raketen dass
es eine mächtige waffe der stadtbezirke
pro woche wurde getroffen wir haben dort
verletzte es wird er jetzt geklärt wie
viele verletzte wir haben und ob wert
hatte ob er toten haben und das
barbarische mieten und in europa im
21sten jahrhundert
sie sind mediziner in ihrem früheren
leben gewesen bevor sie in die politik
gingen sie haben also eine eine
ausbildung als arzt wie ist die
situation in den kliniken und mit die
wiese sieht somit medizinische
ausrüstung die sie jetzt so dringend ja
auch brauchen
massenhafte er wird jetzt blut abgegeben
somit haben wir genug
reserven bis auf einzelne ausnahmen
unsere ärzte setzten sich ein aber
dennoch brauchen wir weitere hilfe und
wir bekommen diese hilfe unter anderem
aus deutschland und wir sind ihnen sehr
dankbar für diese humanitäre hilfe john
cranko sie stammen ursprünglich aus der
hafenstadt odessa darauf studiert seien
sicherlich familie und freunde dort was
hören sie von dort aus den kisten
schleppen wie es da diese situation
und die erste opfer dieses krieges in
der früh gleich am tag als diese krieg
begonnen hat
eine rakete hatte ein objekt getroffen
und 22 personen sind umgekommen elf
männer und elf frauen
es gibt momentan
keine kämpfe dort aus dem land aber die
stadt wird bombardiert auch die vororte
und
es gibt es störungen bei der
kommunikation und es gab auch luftlande
angriffe von franco ich danke ihnen sehr
für diese direkten eindrücke aus der
ukraine und unsere besten wünsche
begleiten sie und ihre angehörigen und
ich hoffe sie in ein paar tagen hier
dann auch wieder im heute-journal
sprechen zu können danke ihnen sehr
das gespräch haben wir aus
sicherheitsgründen für unseren
gesprächspartner aufgezeichnet und
schalten jetzt noch zu unseren
reporterin zunächst zu katrin eigendorf
dem westen der ukraine unterwegs dass
kathrin diese friedensverhandlungen wie
muss man das bewerten
also aus der ukrainischen sicht kann ich
sagen dass die bevölkerung hier mit
diesen verhandlungen gar keine hoffnung
verbindet man traut wladimir putin nicht
zu dass er hier wirklich auf dem
verhandlungsweg zu einer lösung kommen
will und die situation heute hat ja auch
gezeigt es hat ja hier wirklich
gnadenloses weiter vorgehen dieses
krieges gegeben hat wurde schwerstens
bombardiert kiew wird weiter angegriffen
überall in der ukraine auch hier wo wir
jetzt sind richten die leute sich darauf
ein dass diese kämpfe jetzt noch mit
größerer ident intensität geführt werden
dass putin noch brutaler gegen auch die
zivilbevölkerung vorgehen wird und wenn
man sich anschaut wie die delegation
besetzt waren die ukraine hat den
verteidigungsminister geschickt die
russen haben im prinzip zweite bis
dritte garde geschickt und wenn man sich
anguckt was dabei herausgekommen ist
muss man sagen das einzige was man
positiv verzeichnen kann dass diese
gespräche immerhin fortgesetzt werden
sollen sind ja heute eine längere
strecke über land gefahren was für
persönliche eindrücke haben sie damit
genommen
ja ich muss sagen dass in den ganzen
tagen die wir jetzt hier sind ich das
gefühl habe dass die stimmung auch hier
in der bevölkerung immer angespannter
wird die leute werden immer nervöser
das bekommen auch wir zu spüren wir
haben für 120 kilometer fast einen
halben tag gebraucht überall sind hier
straßensperren aufgebaut ich habe mich
so ein bisschen an erinnert gefühlt an
die jahre 2014 2015 und den krieg im
osten der ukraine dass man an
checkpoints seine papiere vorzeigen
musste das volks milizen einen hier
kontrollieren die menschen haben einfach
große angst sie haben auch angst davor
dass russische saboteure hier durchs
land gehen es gibt ja da sehr viele
gerüchte und dass das bekommt man schon
zu spüren es gibt so viele informationen
im moment können wir gar nicht mehr alle
nachprüfen eine davon die leute wirklich
besorgt ist das gerücht dass
möglicherweise putin auch bereit ist die
chemie waffen einzusetzen in städten und
das eventuell sogar das kernkraftwerk
tschernobyl
bombardiert werden könnte und damit im
prinzip durch radioaktivität hier noch
einmal eine weitere
des krieges vorgenommen werden kann das
können wir im moment nicht nachprüfen
ich weiß nicht wie wahrscheinlich das
ist aber das ist auf jeden fall etwas
vor dem die ukraine hier große angst
haben schreckensszenarien dann blicken
wir nach moskau dort wo putin regiert zu
unserem korrespondenten christiansen
dass putin auf die öffentliche meinung
und seinem land ja ganz erheblichen
einfluss hat dass das steht natürlich
außer frage aber spürt die russische
bevölkerung nicht jetzt doch auch dass
dieser krieg auch ihr leben betrifft
ja tatsächlich
sie können die auswirkung des krieges
musikern so langsam in den alltag der
menschen ein zum beispiel beim thema
geld wir sehen hier teilweise schlange
an geldautomaten
leute sich einfach sorgen machen und in
panik sind dass es kein geld mehr gibt
und geld abheben und das führt schon zu
problemen an den geldautomaten und
manchen gibt es gar nichts mehr an
manchen gibt es weniger und die menschen
werden nervös wenn sie die wechselkurse
an denen an den wechselstuben hier sehen
und wieder rubel verfällt und viele
fragen sich tatsächlich in welchem land
sie morgen oder übermorgen leben werden
auch was das thema freiheit angeht was
das thema reisen angeht wenn wir sehen
dass das fliegen immer mehr
eingeschränkt wird dass es kaum noch
möglichkeiten gibt aus russland
rauszufliegen und nach russland
reinzukommen und es betrifft auch zum
beispiel die ganzen ausländer die leben
die ganze fachkräfte die ganzen experts
die für die internationalen firmen hier
arbeiten wo er teilweise schon massig
kapital aus russland rausgezogen würde
wurde und diese mitarbeiter und auch
ihre familien jetzt überlegen wie kann
das hier weitergehen teilweise gibt es
schon familien die sind dann teilweise
schon im ausland und einen elternteil
bleibt noch hier um irgendwie weiter zu
arbeiten oder um das ganze abzuwickeln
und die russinnen und russen gehen auf
die straße aber nicht massiv
und das hat einen grund dass die
opposition hier das haben wir beobachten
den letzten jahren und monaten
konsequent platt gemacht wurde und wenn
man das mit dem wissen von heute weiß
kann man da fast eine art drehbuch
ableiten also zuerst macht man die
opposition bleibt die prominenten köpfe
die auch die möglichkeit haben massen
auf die straße zu bringen die sind
ausgeschaltet zum beispiel wie alexei
navalny und dann startet man diesen
krieg und das ergebnis ist dass niemand
hier übrig ist der massen auf die straße
bringen kann
dankeschön christian und dankeschön auch
nochmal katrin
dass die ukrainische bevölkerung so
tapfer durch hält das liegt auch an
ihrer politischen führung präsident
wolle die meere selensky das kann man
wohl so feststellen ist in diesem krieg
über sich selbst hinausgewachsen und
zeigt sich als ein geradezu begnadeter
kommunikator
wladimir putin hingegen scheint
außerhalb russlands politische
propaganda keineswegs so gut zu
beherrschen wie viel zu trocken auch
seine troll armeen spezialisiert auf des
informationskampagnen im ausland helfen
nicht wenn die welt im netz solche
aktuellen bilder vergleicht auf dem
einen foto war seelands geht zu sehen
und sein verteidigungsminister auf dem
anderen bleiben mir portiert und zwei
seiner generäle hier putin der einsam
hinter seinem schreibtisch hassreden
führt hier selensky der bei seinen
soldaten ist
eindrücklicher können bilder kaum
sprechen und auch sie verstärken die
kampfmoral der ukraine doch das allein
wird ihm vermutlich nicht helfen wenn
sie nicht ausreichend waffen haben mit
denen sie kämpfen können und wenn tut
hinzu allem greift worüber seine armee
verfügt dass er nun indirekt mit
atomwaffen drohte soll nicht nur die
ukraine in angst versetzte wie man
darauf und den usa reagiert berichtet
claudia base
herr präsident fürchten sie einen
atomkrieg rufen die reporter den
präsidenten zu als er heute beim weißen
haus an kommt keine antwort er ist
unterwegs zum gespräch mit den
verbündeten nur so viel vom pentagon
wir haben herrn putins ankündigung
gesehen sie ist unnötig und eskalierend
sie bewerten und analysieren sie die
kündigung
die analysten rätseln was bedeutet es
joe biden sprecherin hält es für das
bekannte muster eine bedrohung
konstruieren die es gar nicht gebe um
damit weitere aggressionen zu
rechtfertigen die praktischen folgen von
putins weisung aber blieben unklar
er hat die bereitschaft erhöht damit
entfernt er gleichsam die sicherung von
der nuklearen waffen das erlaubt es dem
system einen marschbefehl von putin
überhaupt erst anzunehmen und umzusetzen
indem es die waffen ab schießt wenn
putin fürchtet diesen krieg zu verlieren
dann wäre er vielleicht verzweifelt
genug atomwaffen einzusetzen um die
völlige niederlage zu verhindern die
prevent kritik
und gerade weil die usa diese
bedrohungen ernst nehmen bleibt der
präsident zunächst zurückhaltend man
hält putin inzwischen für unberechenbar
also keine eskalation
man ist hier vom abgrund zurücktreten
muss beruhigen wir haben keinerlei
interesse dass auf die atomarer ebene zu
eskalieren oder den einsatz von
atomwaffen zu ermutigen durch ein
versehen eine fehlkalkulation oder durch
wahnsinn
mitten in den schweren spannungen hatte
russland im februar ein manöver
abgehalten auch mit atomwaffenfähigen
raketen nach dem kalten krieg weil der
gedanke an einen atomkrieg in den
hintergrund gerückt zu unrecht so der
experte inzwischen sei alles miteinander
verschmolzen konventionelle waffen atom
und cyber waffen
und das ist der unterschied während des
kalten krieges gab es eine klare
trennung zwischen konventionell und
nuklear und die doktrin der letzten zehn
jahre hat diese trennung entfernt besser
wir richten sie wieder ein
noch hat der us-geheimdienst keine
erkenntnisse über neue bewegungen an
russischen nuklear stützpunkten und
präsident biden sagte später doch noch
etwas die amerikaner müssten sich keine
sorgen machen über einen atomkrieg
die sind putins drohungen einzuschätzen
und wie muss sich die bundeswehr auf die
neuen zeiten einstellen mit geld allein
ist es da nicht getan dazu gleich das
interview mit general eberhard zorn doch
zuerst der bericht von lars boom sagt
über die neuen herausforderer der
bundeswehr sie sind jetzt die
protagonisten einer deutschen
zeitenwende am morgen tritt das
sicherheitskabinett zusammen es dürfte
auch so etwas wie eine
selbstvergewisserung der
regierungsparteien gewesen sein
schließlich gilt es nicht nur sich und
den eigenen leuten sondern der gesamten
deutschen öffentlichkeit eine 180 grad
wende zu erklären wurde ins krieg hat
uns in eine andere zeitrechnung
katapultiert wo wir und das ist richtig
und angebracht
bisherige gewissheiten neu bewerten
deshalb helfen wir als europäerinnen und
europäer und auch als deutsche den
frauen und männern in der ukraine mit
waffen und weiterem gerät die
rhetorische offensive der
bundesregierung wird also begleitet von
einer handlung offensive die der ukraine
versprochenen panzerabwehrwaffen und
raketen seien auf dem weg gepanzerte
fahrzeuge bereits vor ort es gibt also
durchaus möglichkeiten
diese hilft diese lieferungen die wir
nun
unternehmen werden tatsächlich auch ins
land zu schaffen deutlich schwieriger
dürfte es werden die bundeswehr neu
aufzustellen panzer die nicht rollen
kampfjets die nicht fliegen schiffe die
kaum schwimmen die liste der missstände
ist lang 100 milliarden euro sollen es
richten
unser ziel auch mein ziel ist dass wir
im laufe dieses jahrzehnts eine der
handlungsfähig
schlagkräftigsten armeen in europa
bekommen eine der am besten
ausgerüsteten armeen in europa weil das
der bedeutung deutschlands unserer
verantwortung in europa entspricht wo
aber soll zuerst investiert werden was
ist schnell zu besorgen ein neuer
notwendiger kampfjet die dringend
gebrauchten transporthubschrauber oder
drohnen die man bewaffnen kann ich
glaube ist eine sehr richtige und gute
entscheidung wo auch unsere fraktion
eingebunden war wir stehen dahinter und
jetzt kommt es auf die ausgestaltung an
bevor das geld verwendet wird brauchen
wir eine prioritätensetzung sonst gibt
es gießkanne und das wäre verschwendung
auch wenn alle parteien des deutschen
bundestags den angriff russlands auf die
ukraine verurteilen die aufrüstung der
bundeswehr findet nicht überall
unterstützung deswegen sind wir entsetzt
über diese aufrüstung pläne die wir
angekündigt werden und werden die
natürlich auch ablehnen tatsächlich wird
die neuaufstellung der bundeswehr wie
sie stolz und lambrecht wollen wohl
jahre dauern ein wladimir putin der
selbst mit atomwaffen droht dürfte das
einkalkuliert haben
und aus berlin zugeschaltet ist uns der
ranghöchste deutsche soldat
generalinspekteur
eberhard zorn der general und ein
versorger das was viele menschen
besonders
beängstigt ist diese aussage von putin
er habe seine atomwaffen in höchste
aller in eine höhere form von
alarmbereitschaft gebracht wie schätzen
sie das ein was ist davon zu halten
ja wir haben diese aussage natürlich
zunächst mal auf ihren wahrheitsgehalt
überprüft und wenn ich sage wir dann
haben wir das sowohl national getan wie
auch innerhalb der nato und wir nehmen
diese aussage ernst wir verfolgen
natürlich mit unseren mitteln was sich
da gerade tut wir tauschen uns sehr
stark aus innerhalb der nato ich hatte
heute nachmittag ein gespräch mit allen
meinen generalstabschefs aus der nato wo
wir uns ausgetauscht haben über deren
erkenntnisse im augenblick verfolgen wir
die entwicklung wir beobachten dass
weiter und nehmen das zunächst mal so
als maßnahme zur kenntnis ich kann aber
nur nirgendwo erkennen dass in
irgendeiner form tatsächlich
alarmierungs maßnahmen umgesetzt wurden
und wir von einer konkreten bedrohung in
der praxis aufgeben müssen bei dem
stichwort bedrohung muss man ja
unterscheiden bei nuklearer waffen bei
atomwaffen denken da vielleicht jetzt an
die eine große bombe oder ein
interkontinentalraketen also
langstreckenwaffen aber eher noch könnte
man sich ja denken dass er putin
schlimmstenfalls taktische nuklearwaffen
mit kleineren sprengkörper in der
ukraine einsetzen das denkbar ja wir
haben wir sämtliche mittel im auge also
von den strategischen bis zu den
taktischen mitteln
wir können verfolgen wo diese waffen
stationiert sind und wo sie sich bewegen
haben da zurzeit keine erkenntnisse
darüber dass die in einer form zum
einsatz kommt können man muss allerdings
auch hier denke ich alle optionen immer
im auge behalten und sauber bewerten ich
würde hier von vornherein gar keine
maßnahme ausschließen denn bisher hat
putin die dinge angekündigt und in
vielen bereichen auch immer wieder
signalisiert dass er in der lage ist
dinge einzusetzen wie erkennen es im
augenblick nicht aber ich denke wir
sollten auf jeden fall wachsam sein und
da das weiter beobachten doch dann hat
ja keinen eigenen atomwaffen sondern
steht quasi unter dem schutz der usa und
der briten der franzosen und es hat eine
bundeswehr von dem der inspekteur des
heeres vor kurzem sagte eigentlich
stehen ziemlich blank da das ist jetzt
auch schon oft beschrieben worden was
alles woran es alles fehlt dann kommt
sehr viel geld wie sollte man damit
sinnvoller weise umgehen damit die
bundeswehr neu aufgestellt wird ja wir
haben natürlich seit vielen jahren in
unseren
gesamtportfolio mehrere lücken die
fangen an beim einfachen soldaten also
spricht die persönliche ausrüstung auch
das geht regelmäßig durch die medien die
persönliche ausrüstung ist nicht
vollständig bei allen soldaten die wir
veröffentlicht haben wir haben sie nur
bei den soldaten die wir planbar
eingesetzt haben gegenüber der nato also
alle die verpflichtungen die wir im
bündnis eingehen dort haben wir die
vollständige ausstattung bei der rest
truppe zu hause nicht das fängt beim
soldaten an das geht über die
digitalisierung das geht über das
großgerät also in allen bereichen haben
wir in der tat lücken die wir seit
jahren identifiziert haben und wo und
setzt diese 100 milliarden tatsächlich
helfen auch diese lücke nicht zu
schließen geht es denn nur um ausrüstung
oder geht es nicht auch darum dass die
bundeswehr eigentlich eine art neue
aufgabe bekommt nämlich nicht mehr ein
einsatztrupp die im ausland einsätze
kleineren stils macht ist man
afghanistan war groß aber letztendlich
sind es dann doch von der truppe unter
stärke her wenige leute hin wieder zu
einer klassischen bündnis atlantis
verteidigungsarmee ja dem weg
beschreiten die ihr seid 2014 also der
annektierung der krim und sind auf
diesem weg unterwegs allerdings bisher
nicht mit der hinreichenden finanziellen
ausstattung das ist jetzt gewährleistet
und insofern können wir diese lücken
jetzt in der tat auch schließen und
damit auch unsere zusagen die nur der
nato vollständig abdecken und bräuchte
es dafür auch mehr soldaten und
vergessen ja wir gehen im moment von
203.000 soldaten im ziel aus zur zahl
280.000 rundherum das heißt wir haben
noch ein stück des weges zu gehen und
insofern wollen wir an diesem ziel was
wir uns gesetzt haben wir unverändert
fest hatten waren wir noch mal auf die
lage in der ukraine sie waren bevor sie
generalinspekteur man auch gerne rey
beim heer also wurden truppen
truppenbewegungen artillerie panzer das
alles ist in sehr vertraut sie werden
natürlich einen ganz anderen blick auf
die landkarte der ukraine moment schauen
und auf die nachrichten die von dort
kommen sobald man sie bestätigen kann
glauben sie auch dass putin einen
blitzkrieg geplant hatte dennoch nicht
funktioniert oder haben wir leihen da
vielleicht auch ein falsches inneres
teilnehmen also wir hatten am anfang den
eindruck dass putin sie so aufstellt
dass er sehr schnell den stoß nach kiew
nimmt die stadt schnell umschließt und
dann irgendwie in einer zange angriff
auch dann von osten und von süden dann
zusätzlich mit den kräften kommen man
muss dazu sagen dass er offensichtlich
dass unser eindruck die
verteidigungsbereitschaft
der ukraine und zwar nicht nur des
militärs sondern vor allem auch die
moralische unterstützung durch die
bevölkerung unterschätzt hat denn was
wir erleben ist ein sehr tapfer kämpfen
das heer der ukrainischen streitkräfte
unterstützt durch die zivilbevölkerung
und durch eine kluge aufstellung denn
die ukraine hatte lange zeit sich
natürlich auch vorzubereiten auf diesen
angriff insofern stoppt im moment das
vordringen der russischen streitkräfte
befürchten sie dass eltern diesen willen
der wirklich außerordentlich ist den sie
gerade beschrieben haben brechen wird in
dem dann auch zivile ziele massiv
bombardiert werden ist eine
tschetschenienkrieg großen war im
prinzip schon am ende ja wir an im
moment die wahrnehmung dass etwa ein
drittel der kräfte die buden bisher
stationiert hat also entlang der
ukrainischen grenze das ist ein drittel
der kräfte bisher zum einsatz kam das
heißt es sind noch kräfte wir nennen das
zweite und dritte welle sind noch
verfügbar und insofern gehen wir davon
aus dass jetzt die kräfte die danach
kommen dann auch mit entsprechender
feuer unterstützung als durch artillerie
durch luftwaffe dann diesen angriff
weiter vorträgt und wir gehen auch davon
aus dass das im zivilen bereich auch zu
entsprechend collateral schönen und
verlusten führen wird
die einschätzung von generalinspekteur
ich danke für das gespräch hat sein
wissen
was hinter wir haben ja vor einer stunde
es hört dieser konflikt wird nicht nur
militärisch geführt es ist auch einen
wirtschaftskrieg denen die usa kanada
europa und japan gegen putin und seinem
belarussischen vasallen führen sogar die
schweiz hat sich jetzt doch noch den
westlichen sanktions bündnis
angeschlossen und heute war der erste
wochentag an dem die sanktionen in kraft
sind in russland leben die börsen
wohlweislich geschlossen auf den
internationalen finanzmärkten brach der
kurs des rubels massiv ein christian
becker und christoph schneider berichten
anstehen für bargeld lange schlangen
heute vor den geldautomaten wie hier in
sankt petersburg es braucht vielerorts
geduld um an geldscheine zu kommen
seit donnerstag wenn alle zwischen
geldautomaten hin und her um bargeld
abzuheben keiner hat glück und der
andere nicht
die börse heute und morgen geschlossen
der rubel im freien fall eine folge der
vielen sanktionen gegen russland die
russische notenbank kann zum beispiel
nicht mehr auf ihre devisen reserven
zurückgreifen die in der eu und bei den
anderen westlichen verbündeten lagern
etliche russische banken sind aus dem
internationalen finanz
kommunikationssystem swift
ausgeschlossen technologie güter wie
flugzeug ersatzteile und
mikroprozessoren dürfen nicht mehr nach
russland ausgeführt werden die eu hat
zudem ein verbot der russischen
staatsmedien rt und sputnik beschlossen
heute nun bezieht selbst die neutrale
schweiz eindeutig position ab sofort
gelten hier die gleichen sanktionen wie
in der eu vor allem die maßnahme gegen
die russische notenbank ist ein
einmaliger einschnitt eine sehr
effektive und bisher auch noch nicht
angewendete sanktionen auch der
zentralbank die ausländischen devisen
mittel zu sperren das bedeutet dass die
abwertung des rubels voll durchläuft und
das bedeutet für die menschen in
russland eine preiserhöhung aller der
güter die im ausland eingekauft werden
können also eine sehr effektive maßnahme
aber auch für deutschland und die eu hat
der russische angriff auswirkungen
deutschland ist vor allem bei gas und
kohle von russischen importen abhängig
die folgen des kriegs für die
energiesicherheit und die energiemärkte
in europa waren heute thema in brüssel
die eu-energieminister trafen sich zu
einem kurzfristig einberufenen
sondergipfel deutschland hat eine höhere
abhängigkeit von gas von öl und von
kohle als andere europäische länder
daraus ergibt sich die verpflichtung
sich schnell davon zu befreien und zwar
über verschiedene strategien kurz und
mittelfristig in dem wir die importe
diversifizieren
mittel und langfristig in dem wir den
verbrauch von fossilen energien von gas
von öl und von kohle deutlich reduzieren
zur diversifizierung also der
erweiterung der energiequellen gehört
auch eine eigene gasreserve in
deutschland die habeck plant europa will
russland hart sanktionieren und
gleichzeitig unabhängiger von der
russischen energie werden ein
schwieriger balanceakt
welchen preis europa welchen preis wir
für diese sanktionen zahlen werden das
lässt sich noch nicht beziffern aber er
wird zu spüren sein vor allem wird man
sich überlegen müssen wie es bei der
energieversorgung kurzfristig
weitergehen soll wie schnell können
grüne energien ausgebaut werden kann da
ein plötzlicher turbo eingelegt werden
auch ohne putins krieg wäre das nötig
wie der bei den vereinten nationen
angesiedelte weltklimarat heute erneut
verdeutlicht hat alle sechs jahre fasst
er zusammen welche neuen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse ist zur
klimakrise gibt als grundlage für
politische entscheidungen im aktuellen
bericht warnt er bis zum ende des
jahrzehnts müsse entscheidendes
passieren sonst sei das zeitfenster
geschlossen vor diesem hintergrund
stellt sich die frage wie wir heizen und
woher unser strom kommt noch dringlicher
und
die bundesumweltministerin lässt uns
zugeschaltet und frau lemke guten abend
slomka ihr koalitionspartner christian
lindner hatte im bundestag gestern
gesagt
erneuerbare energien sind gemäss sind
frei heizenergie dass wenn sie natürlich
als als grüne koalitions kollegin auch
gerne gehört haben ist das so dass jetzt
die energiewende auch noch eine
geostrategische bedeutung bekommen hatte
ich sag mal salopp windräder windräder
gegen putin
energiepolitik hat glaube ich schon sehr
lange eine geostrategische bedeutung und
das spüren wir jetzt auch in europa und
natürlich vor allem auch in der ukraine
auf die schlimmste art und weise und
deshalb ist es so dass erneuerbare
energien für deutschland eine sehr hohe
strategische und sicherheitspolitische
bedeutung haben zum einen als
unabhängigkeit von rohstoffimporten von
energie importen und zum anderen eben
auch um die klimakrise die zweite große
krise zu bekämpfen
und deshalb ist es eine sehr
strategische entscheidung und es ist gut
dass die bundesregierung das gemeinsam
so sieht ist die abhängigkeit ja dann
doch relativ erschütternd gerade auch
von russland wo man sich die nackten
zahlen anguckt also erdgas kriegen wir
hier in deutschland über 50 prozent
bislang aus russland öl ein drittel
dessen was wir verbrauchen kohle import
auch zur hälfte eine langfristig können
wir uns alle ausmalen aber wir müssen
jetzt auch über den nächsten winter
kommen und über den sommer kommen die
industrie muss laufen klimaanlagen
müssen laufen das kann jetzt kurzfristig
geschehen welche kompromisse müssen sie
dann eventuell auch als umweltministerin
machen zum einen ist ihre beschreibung
erstmal absolut richtig und es auf die
kurzfristige lösung für den kommenden
winter und natürlich auch die zeit bis
dahin zu konzentrieren dafür werden
mehrere dinge gehen wir durch angepackt
zum einen wird dafür sorge getragen
durch eine gesetzliche regelung dass die
gasspeicher bestimmte füllstände im
nächsten winter jeweils aufweisen müssen
dafür werden die betreiber verpflichtet
werden zweitens prüft das
wirtschaftsministerium im moment woher
andere gasimporte kommen können so dass
kurzfristig für den sommer und für den
nächsten winter vorsorge getragen wird
und die
energieversorgung gesichert ist und
mittel- und langfristig müssen wir
massiv in die erneuerbaren investieren
dafür auch die infrastruktur bauen das
wird im detail auch kompromisse bedeuten
und das ist ja auch ich meine sie wissen
selbst ist es schwierig nicht jeder
möchte ein windrad in seinem vorgarten
haben in servicefälle kommen dann auch
umweltschützer und sagen zum beispiel
der stadt zerschreddert uns raubvögel
bestimmten typus als es endlich einmal
in diesem problem herr werden ja wir
haben jetzt ja gerade eine ganz aktuelle
studie letzte woche bekommen dass
beispielsweise der rotmilan ich in
erster linie durch windkraftanlagen
sondern viel stärker durch
beispielsweise verkehr oder sogar züge
beeinträchtigt ist wir müssen diese
konflikte dieses spannungsfeld auflösen
das wären wir vor allem mit guter
planung machen das heißt die länder
müssen gebiete ausweisen in denen massiv
windkraft gebaut werden kann und sie
müssen gebiete ausweisen wo der
naturschutz vorrang hat dass es möglich
das geht ein weiterer vorschlag der
diskussion ist dass man die noch
verbleibenden deutschen akw s die
atomkraftwerke einfach ein paar jahre
länger laufen lässt
ich verstehe das als solche überlegungen
jetzt auf dem tisch sind aber die
betreiber selber haben ja erklärt dass
sie das nicht wollen und das hat
sicherheitstechnische und auch aspekte
der rohstoffversorgung das heißt auch
lkws brauchen brennelemente die kann man
nicht im supermarkt kaufen die müssten
herbeigeschafft werden auch das sind
importe und die frage ein akw sie sollen
ja abgeschaltet werden zum jahreswechsel
jetzt einfach wieder hochzufahren obwohl
es bereits im anschluss betrieb in
richtung auf jahresende ist das ist so
einfach nicht möglich eine ausnahme
situation da muss man dann vielleicht
einfach mal geld reinpumpen um die noch
nachzurüsten also ich weiß das ist nicht
einfach aber jetzt lauter regenerative
energien noch mehr hochzutreiben kurz
vor sich es ja auch nicht einfach ich
glaube es ging nicht darum geld dafür in
die hand zu nehmen sondern dass es
einfach technische restriktionen gibt
wenn die akw es im unterfahren sind
quasi auf den 31 12
so ausgerichtet sind dass es gar nicht
so leicht möglich ist das wieder zu tun
und zweitens sehen wir ja gerade jetzt
in der ukraine
bedauerlicherweise schlimmster weise
dass die akw es dort eben ein
unsicherheitsfaktor sind und wir sollten
in solchen zeiten wo wir von risiken
bedroht sind nicht weitere risiken
hinzufügen und das wäre die verlängerung
der laufzeiten ein situation sagt die
bundesumweltministerin verlangte ich
danke für das gespräch ich danke infos
linke
hintergründe und informationen gerade
auch zu der energie fragen die sich
jetzt stellen finden sie bei uns
natürlich auch online auf zdf heute und
mit dem energie thema machen wir gleich
auch noch mal weiter stichwort nord
stream 2 aber jetzt gibt es erstmal die
nachrichten von hans wolf vor dem
hintergrund des ukraine krieges
verbietet die türkei eine durchfahrt von
kriegsschiffen durch die meerengen des
bosporus und dardanellen laut präsident
erdogan werde sein land die beziehungen
zu russland ebenso wenig aufgeben wie
die zur ukraine
sowohl die türkei als auch russland und
die ukraine sind anrainerstaaten des
schwarzen meeres
mehr als eine halbe million menschen
sind laut flüchtlingshilfswerk der
vereinten nationen bislang aus der
ukraine geflohen auch innerhalb der
ukraine geht die uno von hohen zahlen an
vertriebenen aus knapp 300.000 menschen
sollen schätzungen zufolge nach polen
geflohen sein die eu berät derzeit über
die anwendung einer richtlinie nach der
vertriebene zunächst kein asylverfahren
durchlaufen müssten um in den
mitgliedsstaaten bleiben zu dürfen
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
auch große internationale sportverbände
wie die uefa die fifa und auch das
internationale olympische komitee haben
auf den krieg reagiert und russland von
internationalen sportveranstaltungen
ausgeschlossen
bisher schienen sich thomas bach und la
die mir putin überwiegend wohl gesonnen
das verhältnis ist nun ernsthaft getrübt
das internationale olympische komitee
empfiehlt jetzt auf seiner website keine
athleten und offizielle aus russland und
belarus zum internationalen wettkämpfen
zuzulassen im minutentakt sid der
fußball weltverband nach die fifa
suspendiert russland von all ihren
wettbewerben präsident infantino es
offenkundige sympathien für
autokratische staaten spielen oft mag
keine rolle mehr auch die uefa hatte
zuvor russland die rote karte gezeigt
russische mannschaften werden auch unter
dem dach des europäischen
fussballverbandes bis auf weiteres keine
spiele bestreiten
zum nächsten großereignis den winter
paralympics sind russische aktive noch
zugelassen ob sie am freitag zur
eröffnungsfeier unter neutraler flagge
wie 2018 einmarschieren scheint
allerdings immer fraglicher derweil ist
schalke 04 aus seinem bis 2025 gültigen
sponsorenvertrag mit dem russischen
konzern gazprom ausgestiegen der
vereinsname auf den trikots soll
möglichst bald gegen einen
unbedenklichen nachfolger ausgetauscht
werden
müssen hält sich die dinge ändern können
sieht man besonders auch bei nordstream
2 noch vor monaten schien es doch schwer
denkbar dass das projekt gänzlich
gestoppt wird auch wenn in der neuen
ampel koalition die grünen mit an die
macht kam die der gaspipeline schon
lange kritisch gegenüber stehen aber
dass ein fertig gebautes milliarden
projekt nicht an den start geht das sind
doch eher unwahrscheinlich selbst putins
annexion der grünen war seinerzeit ja
kein hindernis jetzt ist alles anders
die landesregierung von mecklenburg
vorpommern stellt das vor spezielle
probleme zumal sie jetzt die eigenwillig
konstruierte stiftung abwickeln muss die
sie für die pipeline konstruiert hat
mosebach berichtet
ein unscheinbares klingelschild an einem
unscheinbaren haus in schwerin passend
zu der stiftung die so unauffällig wie
möglich ihren geschäften nachgeht neben
klimaschutz ihrer hauptaktivität diese
pipeline zu ende zu bauen und der
umgebung der us-sanktionen die stiftung
soll material beschafft haben personal
logistik was genau sie tut bleibt geheim
manuela schwesig hat die stiftung auf
den weg gebracht und stets verteidigt
heute die kehrtwende seit 6 uhr 45 folgt
ein tweet auf den nächsten fifa urteil
putins angriffskrieg als brutal und
verbrecherisch und fordert die auflösung
der stiftung sowie die verwendung der
stiftungsgelder die vor allem von nord
stream 2 stammen für humanitäre zwecke
schwesig reagiert damit auf heftige
kritik so schrieb ihr der ukrainische
botschafter die heuchelei ist zum kotzen
schwesig krankheitsbedingt gerade nicht
im amt verteidigt sich in den letzten
tagen ist immer wieder versucht worden
die landesregierung als putin freunde
oder versteher zu diskreditieren
ich will sehr deutlich sagen das ist
unsinn ich habe niemals ein gespräch mit
präsident putin geführt oder sein
vorgehen gegen die ukraine unterstützt
gestern im bundestag niemand will auf
der falschen seite stehen friedrich merz
greift an hat ein netzwerk von putin
verstehen ausgemacht dessen vertreter
bis hin zu windigen
stiftungskonstruktionen nichts
unversucht lassen nichts unversucht
lassen mit diesem system geschäfte zu
machen und das ganze dann auch noch zu
versuchen der öffentlichkeit als
gemeinnützig zu vermitteln die
landesregierung pflegt seit jahren
besondere kontakte zu russland nach der
annexion der krim erfand sie 2014 zb den
russland tag als forum der
wirtschaftsförderung gerhard schröder
war als vertreter russischer
wirtschaftsinteressen stets gern
gesehener gast im land im gegensatz zu
schwesig hat er sich übrigens bis heute
nicht distanziert von putin die
landesregierung zieht nun die notbremse
bei all ihren russland kontakten geht
auf größtmögliche distanz zum kreml
nicht nur bei dem thema der stiftung
beim russland tag bei dem ehrenamtlichen
beauftragten des landes mecklenburg
vorpommern selbst bei den regionalen
partnerschaften putin ist für uns an
dieser stelle nie ein gesprächspartner
gewesen nun also soll auch die heftig
umstrittene stiftung abgewickelt werden
geht das überhaupt geht gar nicht lässt
der vorstandsvorsitzende am mittag
wissen erwin sellering war übrigens
schwesigs vorgänger als
ministerpräsident rechtlich sei die
auflösung unmöglich wer das fordere
begehe anstiftung zur untreue
der landtag leuchtet am abend in den
farben der ukraine zeitenwende auch im
nordosten mecklenburg vorpommern wendet
sich ab von russland empört und
enttäuscht
und jetzt nochmal heinz zunächst mit dem
blick auf die speziellen tag direkt und
des russischen finanzsystems ging es
vorhin schon in der sendung schauen wir
jetzt auf den deutschen markt und die
aktienkurse hier in der meine zwee
verlief dieser tag an der frankfurter
börse die anleger sind nervös aber nicht
panisch die zutaten für ein börsencrash
die wären schon da konjunkturprognosen
für das laufende jahr werden nach unten
korrigiert aber die kurse halten sich
dafür noch recht wacker der dax schließt
mit einem überschaubaren - bei einem
stand von
14.400 61 punkten der ausschuss
russlands aus dem internationalen
bankensystems swift und eventuell noch
härtere sanktionen sind so ausgelegt
da sie den schaden für die russische
wirtschaft maximieren aber den für die
westliche welt minimieren sollen wohl
auch deshalb sind die reaktionen der
märkte moderat alles andere als moderat
sind die gewinne der rüstungskonzern
heute ausgefallen sie profitieren von
der zeitenwende bei den militärausgaben
und ihre papiere schnellen nach oben
beim rüstungselektronik hersteller
hensolt ein plus von 43%
leopard-2-panzer hersteller rheinmetall
gewinn 25 prozent und thyssenkrupp
papiere sind mit über elf prozent im
plus die zuletzt dominierenden börsen
themen inflation und corona werden
gerade von dieser neuen realität
eingeholt und verdrängt sina mainitz
vielen dank und jetzt zur krone
situation in deutschland das robert koch
institut meldet 62
1349 neue corona fälle binnen 24 stunden
das sind 11 1518 weniger als vor einer
woche
24 weitere todesfälle kamen hinzu die
sieben tage incidents ist aufgrund
1238 gesunken
bei überflutungen im osten australiens
sind mindestens acht menschen ums leben
gekommen besonders schwer betroffen ist
die stadt lässt dort wurden über 15.000
menschen in sicherheit gebracht das
wasser in den häusern steht zum teil bis
zur decke hunderte menschen sind von den
fluten umzingelt und warten auf hilfe
schwere regenfälle haben ganze regionen
verwüstet in einigen gegenden hat es in
den vergangenen tagen so viel geregnet
wie sonst in einem jahr
viele können es sich um wenn vielleicht
kaum vorstellen aber in normalen zeiten
hätten wir heute ausführlich über die
rosenmontagszüge berichtet normale
zeiten wären aber auch zeiten ohne
corona gewesen auch das hat den karneval
ja schon eingeschränkt und jetzt auch
noch krieg die großen rosenmontagszüge
wurden abgesagt oder verschoben in köln
gab es stattdessen eine große
friedensdemo der besonderen art davon
berichtet ralph goldmann
es war ganz deutliches zeichen der
solidarität bis zu 250.000 karnevalisten
und andere waren nach angaben der
polizei auf den straßen um gegen das
vorgehen des russischen präsidenten zu
protestieren karneval trotz krieg gerne
im kostüm wir sehen ja nicht die jecken
lieder und wir schunkeln ja auch nicht
so als wenn nichts wäre wir sind ja
nicht ignorant eigentlich finde ich
dieses ambivalente auch interessant ich
kriege das eine tolle mischung dass man
sowas zusammenbringen kann dass man
trotz der des karnevals gefüllt trotzdem
dieses gemeinschaftsgefühl auch hier
zeigen kann das passt super zusammen es
ist aber schön zu sehen dass es einfach
sehr viele leute sind die super ernst
nehmen und die auch einfach sehr
betroffen und sehr ernst mit dabei sind
das ist schön zu sehen wie la die mir
putin wird auf einem wagen als trotziges
kind dargestellt dass sich die gute alte
zeit zurück wünscht und auch in
düsseldorf gab es heute einen putin
wagen zu sehen der russische präsident
der sich in einem großen happen ukraine
verschluckt
und mit diesen bildern verabschieden wir
uns in allen acht die für die menschen
in der ukraine wieder voller
ungewissheit und ängsten ist unsere
online kollegen werden sie natürlich
über die jeweils aktuelle entwicklung
ständig auf dem laufenden halten um 0.05
gibt's dann unser heute-journal update
mit gundula gause und uns beide morgen
wieder auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schon gute und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter der weltklimarat hat heute
seinen zweiten teil des neuen berichts
veröffentlicht und die warnung sind
drastisch wetter extreme werden weiter
zunehmen insbesondere wenn wir 15 grad
marke weltweit überschreiten 12 grad
haben wir schon und das haben wir in 100
jahren erreicht dass es also auf den
menschen zurück zu führen von der natur
aus hat es 12.000 jahre gedauert von der
letzten eiszeit bis zur vorindustriellen
zeit bis 12 grad angestiegen sind also
dieser anstieg ist enorm rasant apropos
temperaturanstieg der letzte winter der
meteorologische winter der geht jetzt
nun zu ende und die temperaturabweichung
lag bei 3,1 grad es ist der siebte
wärmste winter und der elf wärmste in
folge höher und der therme theologische
frühling beginnt ja nun kommen der nacht
und es wird größtenteils aufklaren die
temperaturen sinken auf minus elf grad
an den alpen und plus ein grad ganz im
westen deutschlands sind morgen viel
sonnenschein vor allem im osten und im
süden ganz im norden streift uns eine
kaltfront und bringt dichtere wolken
aber es bleibt trocken temperaturen dazu
vier bis zehn grad ja und die nächsten
tage bleiben überwiegend sonnig die
temperaturen
einheitlich bei 5 bis 13 grad damit ein
schöner abend